il a été arrêté alors qu'il était en
reportage avec radio france en fait il
était dans le centre du pays près de
kiev il a voulu en profiter pour aller
voir sa famille d'accord et il a fait
l'objet d'un mitraillage en bonne et due
forme des dizaines d'impacts de balles
sur sa voiture il a accéléré il s'est
pris un arbre il a été sauvé par son
airbag et là elle était sorti du
véhicule et les fixeurs c'est des gens
qui se sont des assistants des
journalistes et journée de tradition et
de la télé spectateur est alors c'est en
fait les quand un grand reporter part
sur un terrain aussi compliqué que celui
là quand on ne parle pas la langue qu'on
n'a pas les contacts sur place on a
besoin de personnes qui sont extrêmement
débrouillarde
qui peuvent appeler tel ou tel bien
trouver le chemin bref il facilite tout
parfois c'est le fixeur d'ailleurs c'est
des journalistes même assuré ce qui
n'est pas le cas de nikita d'accord lui
travaille dans une société
d'informatique et puis il a travaillé
pour plusieurs médias français il a
récemment pour radio france et donc il
s'est fait extraire de son véhicule et
là il a vécu neuf jours d'horreur
à base de détention attachée à un arbre
pendant 48 heures dans le froid
il a eu droit à des simulacres
d'exécution c'est à dire qu'on a laissé
penser qu'on était en train de le
flinguer définitivement
il a été torturé
on lui a passé un couteau sur la joue le
remontant vers l'oeil et il est du droit
des électrodes tortures à l'électricité
il a été séquestré pardon et j'en passe
en a qu'on va tout mais on essaie de me
sens vraiment horrible il a été
séquestré dans une cave avec d'autres
codétenus rempli d'eau bref c'est un
miraculé alors quand il s'en est sorti
mais il s'en est sorti parce que
finalement
est lui-même s'attendait pas en sortir
il a fini par être amené prennent une
route ce qu'ils détenaient on arrête une
voiture on dit emmener l'autre sinon on
va le flinguer d'accord et lui quand on
lui a demandé mais pourquoi oui vous
n'ont pas tué il a une phrase
extrêmement forte iny je crois qu'il
n'avait pas le courage de creuser des
tombes c'est fou c'est incroyable ça
alors on entend ce que nous raconte
christophe deloire c'est complètement
fou et moi là article 8 ans reporters
sans frontières est incroyable dit il
relève sont bonnes et la lame d'un
couteau comme nous avaient dit et fleurs
son deuil des sons le long de sa joue il
menace de lui couper le visage il
explique qu'il est fixeur et interprète
pour des journalistes étrangers mais les
coups pleuvent des coups de crosse de
fusil mitrailleur sur le visage et sur
le corps nikita ce sont des morceaux
dedans dans sa bouche et crache du sang
nikita sont des morceaux de dos voilà il
y c'est vrai que c'est un truc de fou
sergueï est ce que ce que nous raconte
christophe deloire ce soit pour les
téléspectateurs on se dit c'est c'est
incroyable on peut pas croire ça vous
vous nous confirmer que c'est ce qui se
passe pas je confirme parce qu'il n'est
pas le seul l'assuré eu d'autres
d'autres cas il ya eu au legs personnes
qui qui est qu'a subit peut-être un tout
petit peu moins de torture que nikita
mais il a passé quand un 24 heures très
très mauvais et puis les russes bas de
toute façon ils sont connus quand il ya
eu la guerre en tchétchénie quand la
guerre en syrie ils savent très bien en
fait et déteste les journalistes et des
tests et journaliste parce qu'ils savent
que c'est les seules personnes qui vont
raconter ce qui se passe réellement sur
le terrain donc du coup nous m'a déjà on
regarde ça depuis un mois c'est
insupportable parce qu'on vit en direct
en fait les morts les bombes etc et les
journalistes ccc les gens qui qu'ils ont
à supporter assez assez militaire parce
que c'est lent mais face à l'or face à
leurs tortures face à leurs
contradictions face à cette guerre c'est
qu'ils ne disent pas le mot guerre
tandis qu'un journal c'est leur
apportera porte ça et comme christophe a
dit les fixeurs en fait ça
c'est les gens qui sont très
débrouillard et donc du coup et peut
passer même pour un espion parce que ils
connaissent souvent les gens de l'autre
côté parce qu'il faut des fois passée la
ligne de front il faut négocier il faut
négocier avec les mafias locales et donc
du coup c'est les gens qui sont
parfaitement ce sont extrêmement
exposées et heureusement qu'elle les
organisations comme à celle de
christophe qui sont derrière qu'il nous
raconte ça qui les aident vous avez un
central livre maintenant pour pour les
aider et donc ça c'est quand même
quelque chose il ya des bons c'est quoi
les méthodes les méthodes de torture
parce que c'est vrai qu'on a entendu à
christophe ya un instant au tollé les
chaises
là je vais pas vous raconter il n'y a
pas de limite en fait il n'y a pas de
limite mais le problème c'est que ils
sont conscients aussi que les gens qui
torture sont les
criminels de guerre parce que la guerre
malgré tout ce qu'on raconte tout les
toutes les horreurs de la guerre à des
règles et donc la guerre on l'amène
armée contre l'armée et tout ce qui est
en dehors de l'armée contre l'armée on
n'a pas le droit d'aller conventions de
genève il ya qui sont là et donc on peut
pas tuer les civils ont peut pas
bombarder les civils on peut aborder bob
ont bombardé les hôpitaux et on peut pas
tuer les journalistes ne peux pas te
tuer' que torturer les gens c'est
interdit et donc du coup en fait ce qui
est extraordinaire c'est que en fait il
a échappé parce que c'est un témoin et
maintenant vous y vous imaginez devient
accusateurs c'est donc et si jamais il
ya un procès à la haye bah il sera parmi
les accusateurs qui vont se présenter en
dix ans qui va et va raconter comment ça
s'est passé en ne manquant peut-être
reconnaissance ur mais sur les photos
les gens qui ont torturé et donc du coup
moi je suis même étonnée qui acquit le
relâche ils allaient c'est la ville aux
pays bas où il ya la sueur pénale
internationale cette grande juridiction
internationale et on a déposé deux
plaintes déjà depuis le début du conflit
pour les bombardements des tours de
télévision qui sont des objectifs civils
elle n'avait pas d'objectif ou des
usages militaires pour les journées ce
qui sont ciblés et ça a eu beaucoup de
cas d' équipe de télévision de
différentes nationalités qui ont fait
l'objet de tirs délibérés alors même
qu'elles sont identifiés de manière
extrêmement claire comme comme
journaliste et donc on va transmettre
aussi ces éléments sur nikita à la cour
pénale internationale à son procureur
alors on a dans l'arctique on va on va
on va le regretter encore une fois nous
avait parlé tout à l'heure de
fausses exécution les soldats le jette
dans un fossé à côté d'un chien mort
elles soumettent un simulacre
d'exécution en fait un soldat prétend
pouvoir vais vouloir vérifier que son
arme fonctionne le coup de feu une fleur
la tête de nikita ça c'est arrivé
plusieurs fois cédé ce genre de ce
simulacre d'exécution lui là on a eu
deux enfin l'eau traitée
vers la fin de sa détention il a couru
là aussi qu'il allait y passer mais
c'est aussi une manière pour ceux qui
font ça probablement de passer un
message à tous les autres intérêts à
vous calmer c'est la section j'allais
bosser ça dans quel but mais la mesure
où quand on torture normalement un
ennemi c'est pour obtenir des
informations
sur l'ennemi là ils sont torturés
gratuite non à la s'est posée ici non
pas quand tu n'en as tes prières briser
tous les gens qui se retiraient ce
qu'ils vont faire ce boulot qui vont en
temps c'est pour ça qu'il est marquant
c'est ça c'est à la limite c'est
peut-être ça qui la seule qui lui a
sauvé la vie nikita elle va pas c'est
donc près de trois jours attachée à des
arbres dans la forêt les soldats russes
lui avait mis un bonnet pour luc ouvrir
les yeux et enlever ses chaussures vous
dit un soldat remonte son pantalon à la
jambe droite jusqu'aux genoux un autre
lui assène des chocs électriques la vue
boucher le visage collé au sol nikita
est incapable de décrire avec quels
instruments mais ils racontent trois ou
quatre chocs électriques pendant cinq à
dix secondes à chaque fois la douleur
est telle que chaque seconde sonde une
éternité les oddh les deux autres civils
qui l'accompagnent sont également
torturés donc ils étaient au moins trois
à ce moment là avec lui que sont devenus
les il y en a un qui est hospitalisée
gravement blessé l'autre dont on ignore
exactement où il est nous on a fait il
ya un récit et on a corroboré
on a appelé tous les témoins possibles
il ya eu des coups de fil aussi passer
la libération donc on a vérifié et
surtout comme des et sergei on a ouvert
un centre à lviv dans l'ouest du pays
pour aider les journalistes ukrainiens
pour envoyer des casques des gilets
pare-balles faire des formations et
grâce à ce centre de le vivre on a pu
être présent aussi lors de l'examen
médical et l'examen médical a permis de
relever des traces qui correspondent à
ce que vous nous dire sur les liens
suspects alors
oui le truc aussi il faut que les gens
comprennent pas ce que les journalistes
ont fait il porte un casque blanc avec
le taux de presse ça veut dire qu'ils
sont identifiés les gentils fiable
facilement et en fait les gens qui les
enlève ils le font exprès ça ça veut
dire que c'est pas une faute c'est pas
le genre sont en paix alors pourquoi on
dit que la la il a été soupçonné
d'espionnage 1 ce qui est ressorti du
témoignage de nikita c'est ça c'est ça
oui même si lui à une difficulté à le
savoir parce qu'enfin on lui fait pas un
procès verbal
l'acte d'accusation est celui-là c'est à
dire à fait mais il y là les fixeurs
mais comme les journalistes sont souvent
accusés d'espionnage l'espionnage est
extrêmement pratique hier à la
télévision de channel one vous savez la
marina la jeune femme qui a brandi la
première j'ai changé avec elle hier elle
était accusée d'être une espionne
britannique sur sa propre chaîne
vallières
aujourd'hui nous avons fait une
conférence de presse avec une autre
journaliste de la même chaîne
journalistes célèbres qu'à présenter les
grands journaux qui est la figure et qui
pour la première fois a raconté ce
qu'ils étaient les médias propagande de
l'intérieur est là vraiment c'est le
destin d'une femme qui a basculé elle a
vraisemblablement elle sera accusée
d'être une espionne aussi une traîtresse
c'est le genre de mots qu'on utilise en
fait ce qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
voit le fonctionnement des troupes
russes sur le terrain avec toutes ces
exactions dont on parle on voit ce qui
se passe à moscou et l'intensité de la
répression de la mise en place d'un
appareil de censure complètement dément
ou ce qui restait des poches de
résistance du journalisme indépendant a
été liquidée quasiment il reste neuf à y
aller par étape ce journal martyrs et
encore cinq journalistes ont été tués au
cours de l'histoire et notamment le jour
et le journal d'anna politkovskaïa cette
célèbre jean rift russe assassinée
pour l'instant la preuve n'est pas
rapportée que les ordres sont
directement donné c'est à dire que ont
fait pas le lien direct entre moscou et
les pratiques sur le terrain il reste à
l'établir et pour ça il faut des
journalistes pour pouvoir travailler et
malheureusement le kremlin fait en sorte
d'être une boîte noire mais on a du mal
à enquêter